parents care about the well-being of
their children
they want their kids to be safe and
healthy and happy
the coronavirus pandemic has made all
that more difficult
measures aimed at curbing the spread of
the virus quickly met resistance from
anti-mask rallies
to conspiracy theories about vaccines
families are caught up in the middle of
all this with many left wondering
what's good for my child
[Music]
welcome to a new edition of our kobe 19
special i'm monica jones and berlin good
to have you with us
kobe 19 vaccine makers biontech and fisa
have submitted initial trial data for a
vaccine to cover 5 to 11 year olds
production is already being prepared
good news right so let's get our kids
vaccinated
or is there room for doubt
we asked around at a playground in
berlin to listen to what both parents
and children have to say about it
a playground in berlin the news that
covered vaccines are soon to be
available to children affects parents
here
i'm a primary school teacher here in the
neighborhood and i'm always hearing that
children keep infecting each other
despite that i have to say that i'd wait
my daughter is three and the older one
is nearly five and i don't know if i'd
vaccinate them so quickly
my boy is nearly three and my girl is
seven
it would be great if they were both soon
to have immunity
most of all because it's annoying to
constantly have to test the children
especially the one at school
for months biontech pfizer has been
working on vaccination approval for
children from 5 to 11 years old it says
studies have proven the mrna vaccine
safe and effective
they say side effects such as rare cases
of inflammation of the heart muscles are
comparable to those in other age groups
jakob maska a berlin pediatrician
advises parents in germany to be patient
and to wait for the recommendations of
the national vaccination commission not
least because children are far less at
risk
so next month
we want to ease parents concerns we now
know that a child's immune system
functions differently to that of an
adult in the mucous membrane in the nose
and in the throat they have a
significantly better defense than we
adults
they fall ill significantly less often
coronavirus might circulate among
children but according to the robert
[ __ ] institute germany's federal agency
for disease control most cases are
either asymptomatic or follow the course
of a mild illness children are also no
great danger to risk groups such as the
over 60s as more than 85 percent of that
group is vaccinated according to a
doctor from the german society for
immunology
that means it's currently not necessary
to vaccinate children to minimalize the
risk of bringing the infection into the
family
of course it's good if the children are
also immune at some point but ultimately
you have to say clearly that whether
they get this immunity via vaccination
or infection both represent a very small
risk
and what's the word on the playground
would the children take the vaccine
i'd do it if my parents were okay with
it and they definitely would be because
it makes more sense
yes as long as it doesn't hurt
[Music]
for more i'm joined by professor roland
isles he's a director of the digital
health center of the berlin institute of
health at the charity good to have you
with us
now luckily we know that compared to
adults children have a substantially
lower risk of getting severely ill when
infected with covet why is that what is
the secret
well the seeker is very simple so
whenever
we need to activate our immune system to
defend a viral infection we need a
so-called pattern
pattern recognition receptors to be
activated and these pat once they are
activated they actually trigger
downstream production of interferon
which is the primary defense line of our
immune system against any viral
infection now we have found that
children are immensely
effective in our in those
activation of these
pattern recognition factors in
comparison to adults
as a matter of fact they actually happen
to be pre-activated and as such they
recognize the viral infection
immediately and can start start
interfering production and defending the
virus immediately upon a function
but it doesn't work as well uh with with
other viral infections i mean they can
still
get the flu
what's the difference there do we know
why a child's immune system reacts
differently
yes
we have very clear indication that
the coronavirus itself is very effective
in shutting down this early warning
system once they infect the cell now
this is in contrast to for example the
flu virus the influenza virus which
actually comes along with the modest
activation of the interferon defense
system and as such we believe that
in those infections with the flu we do
not depend so much on the very immediate
response and interferon production
itself and that makes a difference
between the corona virus on one side
which actually requires a very effective
and quick response in comparison to the
influenza virus
now children usually fight the virus off
more quickly than adults does this mean
that they're also less infectious and if
not would masks should they still wear
masks would that help
well to the first question
if you are agree that there is a
relationship between the
viral load and the infectiousness of
this individual
initially both children and adults
should be equally infectious because
their initial viral load is quite
comparable as shown in uh in a couple of
other studies now we have shown and
others have also confirmed that that the
uh children are very effective in
uh and in more quickly reducing the
viral load and as such we would
speculate that they are much quicker in
getting down
in getting less infectious over time so
to the second question yes it's still
helpful to wear masks because initially
once before even if you
develop your first symptoms or even if
you're asymptomatic
you're still able as a child to spread
the virus
for the first days after infection and
as such
very much is still a very effective
protective measure
now with all of that in mind right now
would you advise parents to have their
healthy children under 12 vaccinated
once that's possible
yeah i would
clearly answer to this question with a
clear guess gas
for two reasons first of all there's
still an individual risk to to get
severely ill with carbon 19 even as a
child uh below the age of 12 even though
the risk is very low so we do know that
one in five thousand infected children
would develop a severe course of covet
19.
still the risk is still is still there
on the other hand given that the
individual risk is quite low
the societal risk overall is very high
just as an indication in germany we have
a little bit less than eight million
children below the age of 12 and if only
one out and if you assume that with the
with the delta vars the vast majority of
them will get infected one in 5 000 out
of 18 8 million is still a pretty large
number
all right professor isles from the
berlin institute of health at the
charity here in berlin thank you so much
for your time and for sharing your
insights with us
it's a pleasure thank you
now one worrying side effect of the
pandemic is an increase in child labour
in developing countries lockdown
measures often meant the loss of income
with no compensation
here's a story now from ghana where more
and more kids are forced to pick through
rubbish for scrap metal and plastic to
sell to recycling dealers it's a
hazardous job that hardly helps to make
ends meet
this would be dangerous work for anyone
but even more so for children
these youngsters have no choice but to
expose themselves to the danger of this
trash just to eke out a living during
the covered 19 pandemic
muhammad latif is scavenging for plastic
and metal that can be recycled here in
ghana children are on the front lines of
the scrap business
picking through the garbage is how i
earn my living
i can sell the scrap material to dealers
life is expensive now because of the
corona virus pandemic and people are
dying
if i scavenge like this i can provide
for my needs
the children are also exposed to
exploitation
the dealers who buy their materials are
not that much better off themselves
they are also just trying to survive
there have been reports of dealers
cheating children paying them less than
what the materials are worth
they use the scrap metal to make pans
zinc and aluminum from vehicle parts
with a surging number of children
collecting waste in accra exploitation
by dubious dealers is taking place more
frequently
this is just one of the tragic results
of the pandemic in ghana
not only are more children being exposed
to dangerous toxins but to exploitation
as well
before we go here's a look at some of
the other kobit 19 stories making news
around the world
russia reported a record number of daily
corona deaths on sunday reaching 890.
the country has the highest death toll
from the virus in europe totaling nearly
210 000 health workers say the lack of
young people getting the jab is
prompting the spread of the virus to
relatives who subsequently die
new zealand will phase out its target of
eliminating the coronavirus within its
borders pressure has mounted on prime
minister jacinda ardern after a series
of strict measures including lockdowns
and prolonged border closures she says
the strategy will shift to learning how
to live with and control the virus
murk says it's almost ready to seek
authorization in the united states for
the world's first pill shown to treat
kobit 19 directly the drug company says
molno piravir reduces the chance of
hospitalization and deaths by half
australia's government has also already
expressed interest in the medicine